well welcome Jonah as a lifelong Doctor
Who fan thank you for that you did in
the day of the don't tell when you think
it was stunning ladies and gentlemen
Stephen thank you for including mr.
Hawke because it's further than the best
calcu who have done I'm pearl thank you
for changing it into mr. Holmes
yes you're very welcome anytime
thank you for stopping being poem again
that's not no and even when did you
decide that you were going to do a
regeneration sequence with John it was
actually while we were making there the
doctor we were working on a weapon what
we're gonna do to the prequel his people
and I realized because we're doing the
50th we lost all three doctors one week
before the angles so I knew it wasn't
going to involve any more the doctors of
the show in my fanboy but we can
actually do the regeneration
so we got in touch with mall and said
would you come in and in secret do
original you know do a six-minute
regeneration intercept and he not
unreasonably asked to see a script and I
said I haven't written it yet but could
you let me know if it's okay to write it
and he very kindly agreed to that and to
be honest it was done on the last two
days of the shoot and I actually think
it's not the best thing to be done I had
not thought what I think it's dead yeah
yeah I think it turned out really really
well and when you happy with the way
your doctor was dispatched
with your his story lane you know there
wasn't any time to think about really it
was only afterwards when we shot it it
went home kind of digested it they
really said kid and yeah well it ought
to be a question yeah I think it was a
neat way it was a good way yeah getting
to make a choice you know you know about
the warrior was well the beautiful sign
there John but when you got this script
would be at the doctor was it easy for
you into flesh the warps that were on
the page what was so this frame is that
you were kind of proud of absurdity if
you see what I mean because when all
three of us there all the time sometimes
it very jokey Russian sometimes in quite
serious fashion but we don't know the
same president of course
so it was it requires one or two
questions in terms of but how are you
portrayed but actually the limit as it
were you guys are the desperate to ask
questions to open the floor to the
audience with the roving mics who'd like
to ask the first question
some when the alleged yellow check there
is here you hi I'm Stephen thank you for
the past few years it's been amazing big
fan and John how have you felt
Vulcans by the thoughts of you fans the
thoughts of you brigade has it been
different from anything that you've done
before do you meet the news that you
made here yeah that's been amazing I
love it I got around town I have
conversations oh that's fantastic
and as for they the company they were
they were quite terrific I realize that
it's there's a lot of it is fun but
there's an enormous amount of extremely
hard work goes into it I know there's
not a lot of time and everything has to
get learned we don't have much time to
yourself
but now as far as that there will be
until they're part of the followers have
got their I've got a great time with
them I must say very good thank you all
thank you for that have you found have
you think that your family or has
suddenly increased since they've got to
do that side of it definitely has yes
new section how difficult was it a
chance you which made the war doctor
because not nobody knew who he really
was how difficult was it to portrayed as
a villain or a hero
well I think it was a very clever device
nobody those areas of the story in which
no doctor no present doctor the ticking
who wants to go back to
and to invent shall we say that's right
since I could turn the date was like
giving them a section on the line I
thought it was a brilliant device very
very clever dramatic device altogether
really say more than that
there's Stephen you said earlier but it
was quite a traumatic tank for your
writing it where you pleased with this
final result because I certainly set
about the best standing ovation at the
end of it but you I was massively
pleased we hope then down but I've
genuinely and in my heart never been so
terrified of how something will be done
in my life hi on the day is going to go
out all over the world at once to that
record and that record rigging some
organs all I could think about was what
if everybody hates it once in the world
I'll be the single most unpopular person
most suddenly ever I'll be sympathy is
the 85 around 77 billion people that's a
lot even by my standards that's
unpopular so I was terrified into going
up I was told it took me probably about
24 hours to realize it then don't really
well because I immediately went on to
that after show do you remember and we
were caught in a time loop the most
insane experience ever
we will be we were being misunderstood
by half of equals it was Australia yes
yeah so I was still a little
successively yeah absolutely thrilled
couldn't have gone better
so Steven you have cast join not Peter
what have you looked for all three toes
when you have been casting well each
time it's different
the first time I was replacing David
it'd be magnificent and wonderful is the
doctor and it was I was just wondering
how anyone had followed us how you would
fill that space with someone who would
replace him that simultaneously please
the people who liked it
I can't we go older but we ended up
doing even younger and just because Matt
came in and he's just a star he's just
carved out of solid star when it came to
Casting the war Johnson and I've got the
emails so this is not made up we were
saying what we need is we need a
terrifying old veteran doctor someone
like John her that we'd never get in
honestly what we say so something
hopefully suggested that we offer the
script joint works which you know is is
a good way of getting a John Hurt time
we skipped off to John I remember
getting the message he's reading it
tonight and with Peter Capaldi it was it
just popped into my head I knew he was a
fan cuz every time I saw a VEC event I
want to talk about the thick of it he
talked about Doctor Who which is very
annoying for me I've just thought what
chance what if nobody ever asks if he'd
actually do it and we asked him in and
he's doing it we know he's amazing
you know Peter that report yeah
about the same age how do you think he's
gonna know something I think we might
have the best ever
doctor on island since what I think I
think he's got everything you know as
well as being hugely skillful what I
love about this is he's brilliantly
employment he's able to intern and it's
a lot of clever clever connected
intelligence eating another thing when
he's funny he can be simultaneously
scary I think he Spencer
honestly I think it's no I think I think
we're weird retreat you know maybe so
it's mostly birthing say there's a
reason flowers at night yeah there
wasn't as you explained to me in this
short message you said it was it danger
big leak so you were gonna put it out
within the next few hours this was late
morning up the 14th and I think I don't
know I was working at the put on some
Browns middle of the day than it was and
we may do this again may may always do
this in fact we knew some people had the
information and they were starting to
post here the information and we wanted
it to be a surprise when we cut to Paul
saying that possibly not the doctor
You're Expecting we wanted everyone all
my god
and that would equal rocks so much for
them but there was this already a
website and a photograph of all next to
it their users were about the peephole
so it was upsetting the close so I just
remember just pulling up saying Luke
let's just tell nobody we're doing it
let's get everybody on Hummers notice
and just put it out on as it turns out
the doctor's birthday that's a shame a
mini-review is it mattering interests
put your hand up if you were completely
surprising the vault on Belkin should've
been everybody shooter with everybody
when when my plan to close down the
internet completely starting with
Twitter takes effect life will be better
than we will learn to communicate again
we're taking another question please
canola sauce even if if it had gone out
with a week I think it was it was for
most people tone Baker everybody shut up
and and the internet so you know it
makes sense it's porn elsewhere you
don't leave it is not maybe two days
away
I've talked to
it's now John and the internet chosen
was so are there any more plans for Paul
or John to be available many so you
gotta claim them well first of all no
he's not the George Lazenby of doctor
here that's completely unfair much as I
love on a Majesty's Secret Service there
is a central problem in it isn't that
that's and also he's feeling more than
one episode so there you go as to what
the doctor at this moment to be honest
it's all about launching a new doctor
and there is no more fragile moment more
dangerous moment in Doctor Who and then
when you're launching the new guy it's
just difficult so it's all about you
take a penalty for now and that's all
I'm thinking about is giving him the
biggest launch possible and imprinting
him on a generation of children in
particular that are adults too and
saying this is the one only need to do
that you don't want to think the doctor
was just a committee of people standing
behind one title he want to think he is
one man and that's him as for what else
we will do even if I did have plans I
would live at a different airlines and
if I then told you about my plans those
themselves be lies right so what's the
fun in asking me thank you
don't you see Joe we're here I thought
you're a magnificent Caligula and I
Claudius it was absolutely magnificent
I just had to say that where you ate the
embryo the idea that I was good casting
for this another question please
how do you feel when more faster you
everyone are not you regenerating John
Hannah yeah that's like I got everywhere
though I was really excited
yeah I was excited I said you know when
you work as an actor you just hope that
the script occurred you know the
material yeah that's the [ __ ] that's the
one and only thing I went there good
you've got you know you got yourself a
start I was really thrilled I was
telling this I guess that like Steven
explained things happen very quickly but
it was it was obvious very quickly that
it was something really rather clever
and it was when you think it was only
six minutes long six not that long
and yet you know a surprise a genuine
surprise is going to and we took we had
a regeneration there were some some old
storylines you know resurrected a few
old things gonna be visited it was
really quite ingenious and why would you
not be excited yeah I was very excited
at that Steven why did you choose the
chronic car is greener Morbius so
favorite story room service it just I
honestly can't remember it says you know
as I told you the 50th was a stressful
time
I just got old would be funny if it was
come on let's go back there it's like
competition for the most obscure
continuity reference you could some days
you just entertain your support I always
thought I'd like to join I think I live
in good events sacred flames take it
five
this is a joy well Stephen said earlier
they took the part quite quickly and
I'll just wondering what your reasons
were for that sorry white pops it
quickly why I took it so quickly is it
no greater living because this was the
50th anniversary of something which was
a National Monument whether you were a
different T of day of the program or not
it was obvious that what was going to do
something like that
wrong also it was it was extremely low
why they were so surprised that I should
be attentive because it's as if it's a
second great show it's it's been around
50 is you and that floor it was and it
got built in strength
it was started off as a little adult
piece then it became a quick child
please and by the time that I was
involved with it it was mainstream so
it's a know of course I was going to do
I had a great time doing I got a talk I
was told a great deal by be able to talk
to who's I say bye but if not a David
you not to make us - after the whole
bracketed on how did you feel John I'm
so I'm gonna define for gold again doing
a regeneration was that something that
you were happy to do to change up to
Chris
and it's an established thing as well it
was yeah
yes it's kind of a privilege to be very
clear about many people have what did
you think of your costume John Vickers
appeasing why are we kind of walk to
town he's very good very very empowered
how hard work is right yeah and he got
some together some very good sales and I
just said he said I hoped you'd say is
that I think we did it in five minutes
but he got it together you got about
three different coats
designing so I didn't take too long but
yeah yeah and Paul you had a new costume
as well were you happy with that
that was how it does hold on oh yeah
this little discussion about it but he
didn't need to because when I was there
it was a nice idea because it was a big
TV look more whether they go back sit in
the walls for literally so that work
like that look at it one little car the
regular looks like three of those
deities to cheating well Mike is it
still I pray you really do a lot of them
don't
audios the Big Finish
stay even when your unfinished with the
television series would you consider
writing but to audio straight that
speaking John's doctor sorry were you
asking when I when I've done the Doctor
Who well I carry on doing it all of you
oh no no typically on television on TV
well I think of I think by the time I'm
stretching me out of Carl if it might
not be my first request probably won't
happen but I do I do very much like they
finish on the world for one a visual
starring Paul Anka so it was I think I
think they do wonderful work and I
strongly recommend the miles I was
telling them Briggs I'm writing in Big
Finish gaps so that he can put some more
stories and they say right there's even
some trenzalore for AG's go in there we
don't know how long how long he was
messing around before he goes on the
played in the Snowman you've got you've
got your chance and I I tell the doctors
as they come through as far as I'm
concerned that I'm very happy for them
to go on and have their Big Finish after
life that's the the audio adventures
that we will be knocking on your door
any minute
no John I would say there was a young
hotshot was standing there was desperate
to ask the question yeah stand up can
take the mic to speak go ahead what's
the question what was it like playing
hide away or sit down
I wasn't like doing it was it down and
and the TV series events
oh I did enjoy doing the boy song like
shakedown yes yeah it's quite a long
time ago to know that I always wanted to
play a rabbit so I think I enjoyed it
yeah
thank you very much another question
please um so I do marketing and
entertainment and I would like to ask
Steven market that the most TV shows of
trying target and specific market doctor
who has held audiences for 50 years and
you there are obviously many types of
people here with such a wide audience in
so many ages and people does that ever
have an effect on the writing and is it
ever tricky to kind of cater to so many
different kinds of fans I don't think
you can write television or make
television or any kind of entertainment
I'm trying to tailor it to an audience
because because you haven't met them and
you're never gonna get remove them all
and ask them questions you just you just
make stuff and do stuff that you find
entertaining and hope somebody agrees
with you I promise you every hit show
ever made has been somebody in the room
just thinking I think that would be
brilliant I'd watch it sometimes you are
the only person that watches that's
happen to a lot of my shows occasionally
you make it short where your own
obsession is shared by many others but
you can't you can't set out to get a
vast international audience or if you
can I have the faintest idea how to do
it I promise you you can only decide to
do what you care about and what you're
passionate about so slightly down on
serving up the truth don't they think
that's another question please yep thank
you
my since the second teaser trailer
there's been a lot of discussion as to
whether the doctors still a good man and
this question slightly off topic
I was rubbering what characteristics do
you think personally make a good man and
which if any of the doctors do you think
let's display them I think I think
trying to do the right thing is the only
thing you can call good
I mean accidentally doing the right
thing by mistake that's not good and
doing the wrong thing even though you
were trying to do the right thing that's
not evil the aspiration to be good is
what makes a good man and the doctor
always falls into that into that
category
the fact is anyone who ever ask
themselves am i a good man is one so
that's like these quiet the teaser
trailer for you am ia good man ask the
doctor the answer is yeah thank you
Stephen when you finish the script it's
there for
do you read alert devices I do that all
the way through three writing it I know
you you have to know sometime if you've
read this icons in line you have to
which have to many many times let's be
clear we have to check if an active as
bad as we can say it I'm hoping that
somebody else is good so yeah you do
that all the time it's meant to be out
load and it's meant to be hard not rare
exacting event yeah now join and hull
has both been involved in the Alien
franchise
John can you debunked this mental River
is it true that when they were to
proceed with the alien costing from your
chest that they didn't tell some of the
cast members is that true well of course
that's not true because I mean that they
all had scripts of the new book with you
okay - huh what I didn't know was how it
was going on the thing is that really
decided to put explosive traps all the
way around my breakfast returned yes so
the very moment that he came through the
capsule and often the blood splattered
all over the glass and we were using
that and then the afternoon who did the
whole thing again but then of course
everybody knew what was going on it was
the membrane the membrane of a pig's
liver and a member ID of the pig's liver
is lips tickle some of the morning was
the one that was used we did the whole
nother scene in one morning the cast
should have understood what was going to
go on because when he was using five
cameras and nobody uses five cameras and
that is an extremely good reason the
five cameras means five crews which is a
lot of money being Israeli at that time
who is not particularly bankable
director because though he be everybody
had fingered him to be a big successful
director he hadn't naturally produced
the big successful film at that time but
you can't be follower with when you
brought the directors part of alien 3
because your character it's a completely
different film with dolly Zoomer if I
was up was promoters happy as Deng
Fincher was I think
don't think it can't be many worse
things to happen to a food on a film
taking off you he was a young guy at the
time in his mid-twenties over the years
so that we shouldn't since he started
with it seems to the wall then in a
sense he had the last luck he became the
big play misdirected years later got his
own cut of it I'm a cup was great
because it made a lot more sense it was
genuinely the good thing that he plan to
do and in that spirit was another
question please
Susan say the right there we got the
banker stand up please thank you
hello so say that the doctor reaches the
planets where the only way to
communicate is for song if you Steven
had to write a musical episode for
Doctor Who
would you prefer to write the song and
lyrics or choose or there's nothing like
greed and choose songs that already
exist and also I would like each of the
doctors to give me a trademark song or
piece of music for their doctors that
represent them
has happened to the internet I was
already in the so you know huge stories
about one apartment I don't believe in
it so there you go already another
question please
did you expect that there be a lot of
characters costume didn't catch the end
of that sorry when we design Peter
Capaldi's outfit maybe what I because I
I'm not brilliant in costume that's all
I have to say I sorta myself let the the
actor go off with the costume designer
and and come back and show me and I know
Peters very image of his clothes and had
very strong ideas about he wanted his
doctor to look looking for I was quite a
jumper we actually see see a man in
action not so much
it needs more song but more style than
that when you get a flash of the red
lining yeah it doesn't call / Weaver
it's not in action not so much
you're a good more aware that he's ready
he's severely puritanical and he crosses
the doctor oh then he fellows in the
fight between about 55 and 60 years old
that remember the first skin is English
unit clothes 69 to 72
that's what
that's why I think my toes as well as
they my my criticizes my colleagues
ahead yeah
oh maybe this gets all the parts of the
musical number about to you bringing up
the time you've I never saw earlier the
wibbly-wobbly away and a thing come on
man you can see it there don't hold it
start work immediately do you know I uh
of all the things I've ever written that
bloody crazy wiggly wobbly timey wimey
seems to be the only line that's really
stuck yeah I saw once I was sooo in
Edinburgh with this this is area of all
famous Scottish greatest and most famous
phrase and I was obviously looking at
and wistfully wondering when my time
would come
and realizing answer was never and sue
said you know you'll get one of those
one day and it will say wibbly wobbly
timey why
that's probably what I deserve one final
crafter who's next I might stand up and
speak you may have to repeat that with
the mics lighting their first area
Doctor Who and Torchwood before and I
was wondering if that was going to be
resolved or if there without an
explanation um
truthfully I don't think it's something
you have to resolve because audiences do
understand that different actors can
play you know different parts that's
fine on the same actor can play
different parts well I did remember that
when Peter Capaldi turned up at
Torchwood Russel said he had a plan in
his head but why he looked like the guy
and fires of Pompeii so I emailed it and
said what was the explanation and does
it fit that the new doctor
and it sort of does and so in a very
low-key way yeah well we'll address it a
bit it won't be a major deal because in
the end people know the real reason is
he's played by the same what's really
worrying me is Karen Gillan in fires of
Pompeii that's just inexplicable I gonna
get to that event ladies and gentlemen
please show your appreciation for the
dress